what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch an
honest trailer from screen a junkie
spider-man far from home they finally
did it guys
this Thursday I'm gonna be returning to
screen junkies for movie fights which
they have switched to a monthly show
brought the format back to five rounds
it's gonna be action oh this is a
spider-man video but it's gonna be all
DC themed you know cuz the Joker I'm
actually gonna be riding with one of my
competitors at Grier over to there I'm
nervous about it it sounds like it's one
of those fights where the ones who are
most familiar with the comics of DC will
probably have a better chance of winning
these are you insane knowing who I'm
fighting against I'm like oh man these
guys are for sure important eligible
then beat still it should be fun I'll do
my best that's all I can do that is my
awkward promotion for the movie fights
this Thursday let's watch that presented
by movies anywhere you are movies
together at last download the movies
anywhere app today and bring your movie
collection together consolidate with
from the studios who act like divorce
parents arguing over where their kids
fence Christmas comes an MCU ketchup
movie that's all about the Tony Stark
shape pole in the universe you sure it
isn't even wants to make a spider-man
movie Iron Man Iron Man game juicy
kernels of phase 4 yeah spider bait goes
on vacation please know it seems a
little Disney close to me wake me up
when he gets to space Wakanda save
between setting up the next episode of
MCU hop aboard the kind of team euro
roadtrip sex romp not seen since Euro
tread road trip or sex drive where he'll
be joined by very own Stifler two
teachers but from a 96 oh yeah
[Applause]
you know they used to execute people on
this bridge
[Music]
I read in the secretly bows in mind and
John Tennant to bring an army of the
insane she seems nice
I just hope she doesn't end up like his
other girlfriends my wife and I split up
Jake Gyllenhaal shines a fishbowl with
haunted house powers Tony Stark
you know the already dead guy because
dude's company was like an arc reactor
for haters just get a job at hammer
industries you dorks hey now there's an
idea
the real as Mysterio plays on
spider-man's only weakness getting it in
the face with a train just getting
ridiculous
no he'll strike to the one thing Peter
likes most of all an adult male who
isn't / being out on his ass lovely you
dress yes
sticky rice pudding some house watch
Mysterio playing his trust
just do any did you throw an
assassination program that Tony about to
a teenager which fine that's good news
thing activating instant kill no no but
this murder machine is hidden inside a
pair of sunglasses that's the world's
most commonly lost item so get with how
the third spider-man to which perfectly
a second spider-man 3 that audiences
won't see until [ __ ] schedule clears up
in 2024 but know what you get a
spider-man movie every year Gyllenhaal
and my god thought about Zen Daria trick
fury 90 day to make Beyonce oh oh till I
make about happy Black Widow oh thank
you you would be the smartest guy in the
room the most qualified and no one cares
unless you're flying around with a cape
or shooting lasers from your hands no
one will even listen
[Music]
was friends with Ironman Zuzu
Thompson your son almost died like twice
you monster he to fail a flag which one
is the most powerful on screen version
watch this video we made this assist and
lies footage to answer in a new episode
of our new series our levels click here
to watch now at v10 to learn something
this episode was brought to you by
movies anywhere you choose where to
purchase your favorite movies we'll
bring them together in one place movies
anywhere download the app a mountain
you're into every generation every time
I hear about a new sponsorship from like
oh that's what it's like to hear about a
new sponsorship if you need a shout out
on more youtube channels this is really
funny
I like their perspective they really
hone in on just for the title the boy
who knew man and yeah because that is
like the thematic elements of pretty
much this whole honest trailer I felt
this seemed to be a bit of like a
cynical kind of honest trailer I knew
that they like they like the movie have
listened to their reviews they you know
then hearing this approach to it I feel
like if people don't hear their actual
reviews of the movie they can have it be
a little misconstrued that they don't
actually like this film but they're they
really do either the way I thought this
was really well done I love the gags
they included in here that were so funny
cuz a lot of times what makes just laugh
are the punchlines that they have you
know or the things that you didn't
necessarily pick out that they've then
pointed out to you like the whole anime
like every single male on screen has to
hit on that male dolt who is not into
anime that is so true so accurate yeah
as I was watching I was trying to think
of what other adult males have we seen
interacted that man yeah exactly because
they all are pretty much in
ever since to tell me she's freaking hot
I'm sure if Mysterio met her he'd be in
her tell of course why wouldn't I want
any of it well you know it's just like
why didn't rosemary Harris get the same
treatment yeah yeah who's that
Aunt May from spider-man will the Sam
Raimi right right right
unless it's Rosemary Clooney and I'm
miss speaking but no that's George
Clooney from that black spider yeah
there gags like with the trombone with
the debbie downer oh yeah then when they
did the gwen stacy moment oh that was
one of the funniest again in terms of
like artist trailers as of late that's
one of the funniest moments I've seen
that they pulled off I think of that
that was unexpected yeah because already
did the rule of three would MJ and then
they'd do it which is a good point well
extra yeah then they do that little
extra one with Emma so me and kill that
was hilarious but even Spiderman far
from home was shot in front of a live
studio audience
oh great way to dig at that because that
was one of the distracting elements of
the movie to me is how sometimes it
would break out it's just we're a comedy
movie oh these characters are cartoons
yeah which the teachers certainly are
and also really pointing out to you
about how everyone who seemed to be from
Starke really does turn into some
crazy-ass villain my mind always went to
oh yeah the the spider-man villain
seemed to all assent from some type of
weird history would start but then they
showed that the light above six men like
oh well you know what they say you
either die a stark employee or you live
long enough to become a bit talk so much
about spider-man now there's more we can
say there's more to break down here
especially the new deals made I think
always traders is always the best way to
cap it off and now we never have to talk
about this film again the reason why is
because I noticed that well do our
reviews usually non-spoiler then a
spoiler you might watch like a new rock
stars video or something to really get
the in-depth breakdown all that stuff
that comes out when the movie has just
arrived all the theories and everything
and then what honest trailers I feel
really they really hit up especially for
me is it's just a movie yeah well it was
bring it back to the fund instead of all
this serious stuff that says the room
around this
guys commentary of it all yeah well yeah
and there's also just that aspect that
you know it's usually a longer period of
time before the honest trailer comes out
so you know yeah for the blu-ray exactly
the home video released coming around in
yeah it does feel like the perfect
moment in time to put a little stamp on
this in word covered yes that is true
I know it's a lot of stairs once they
cover it and like it's time to let it go
now we're at peace especially for us
because we have talked about there's
nothing more for us to dissect
especially with anything with the word
Marvel in front of it they did really
remind me though of how would Mysterio
how they really tried selling I said he
wasn't a villain in the trailers and
stuff I remember those days when there
like not only does the groupie work
together who's gonna be good we were
like everyone was thinking the same
thing I'm so smart look how smart I am I
didn't believe it okay we're smarter yes
I'm smart oh you guys thought it you
guys yes we ought to weigh out everyone
did we all do they all agree that this
ruse wasn't going to last all right guys
we'll make sure to catch me on movie
fights do my best to keep up with
everyone else there how bout at this
Thursday you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell I'd like to end this with a page in
the day shout out to a man named Philip
J Smith jr. Philip I'm not gonna lie man
you and I were having a seriously great
back and forth for quite some time there
there was a solid period for you and I
we're talking an awful lot I thought we
were gonna have some long ongoing
conversations now it's been quite a
while I have no idea where you went
did you just that was that I was
snapping away the blimp they did blip in
it I'm just like you two get back to me
cuz I miss you on an unrelated note
thanks for all those letters you've been
sending me it's been really nice getting
to know you over this past month you
know I feel like I really have a place
in your life now and I can't wait to
meet you and move in together pretty
soon so take care of Phil I'll see you
Oh